und jetzt das heute schon mal mit kaiser
richter und christian sievers guten
abend hinein das sparschwein der spar
tag das sparbuch am besten gleich zur
geburt über generationen galt in diesem
land die goldene regel wer spart gewinnt
das ist vorbei schon länger und heute
mehr denn je denn die banken müssen wenn
sie geld bei der zentralbank parken
wollen
seit heute noch mehr zahlen als bislang
die europäische zentralbank hat den
sogenannten negativzins hochgesetzt
die kunden werden das merken wer spart
bekommt probleme jahrhunderte alte
weisheiten stehen auf dem kopf wenn du
den wert des geldes kennenlernen willst
versuche dir welches zu leihen hat
benjamin franklin einer der gründerväter
der usa gesagt der oberste euro banker
dagegen versucht alles um geld billig zu
machen kredite anzukurbeln und ist sich
dabei bewusst dass er dem sparer schadet
und zwar massiv stefan schlosser
berichtet tresore sollen sicherheit
geben genau danach suchen seine kunden
sagt walter drei seiner seit 45 jahren
baut und verkauft er geldschränke die
nachfrage der kunden steige seit jahren
auch dank der ezb sie legen das geld in
teure uhren goldbarren oder krügerrand
münzen da haben sie wenigstens die
sicherheit dass sie diesen wert noch
behalten
beim geld gibt es diese sicherheit nicht
ist die inflation höher als die zinsen
auf sparguthaben verliert es an wert
bei einem prozent inflation und null
prozent zinsen werden aus 10.000 euro
nach einem jahr 9900 euro damit
entstehen natürlich bei den sparern
reale verluste die sich dann über die
jahre natürlich doch deutlich ansammeln
und die private altersvorsorge wird
extrem schwierig für die deutschen
haushalte
sparen lohnt sich also kaum noch eine
kehrtwende nicht in sicht im gegenteil
die zentralbank kündigt heute an den
geldhahn weiter aufzudrehen ab november
sollen jeden monat anleihen im wert von
20 milliarden euro gekauft werden und
banken müssen zukünftig bis zu 0,5
prozent zinsen für bei der ezb geparkt
das geld zahlen die analyse hat gezeigt
dass ein großer grad an geldpolitischer
unterstützung weiterhin nötig ist für
eine nachhaltige annäherung der
inflation an ein niveau von etwa zwei
prozent
so soll die wirtschaft in schwung kommen
mehr kredite mehr investitionen
steigende preise so die theorie für
banken wird das geld verdienen aber noch
schwieriger sie könnten verstärkt die
kunden zur kasse bitten und eine
möglichkeit ist zu sagen dann machen wir
die einlagenzinsen negativ oder wir
schreiben die gebühren hoch das kann
durchaus passieren
es ist fünf jahre her da gab mario
draghi ein versprechen ab er wollte
alles tun um den euro zu retten doch
viel mehr möglichkeiten bleiben der ezb
nicht wachstumsimpulse müssten jetzt von
den staaten kommen sagte trage heute und
damit meint er in erster linie
deutschland angesichts der sich
abkühlenden konjunktur und bestehende
abwärtsrisiken sollten regierungen mit
fiskalischen spielraum effektiv und
zeitnah handeln
das geldpolitische pulver verschossen
kaum unterstützung von den regierungen
es ist kein leichtes erbe das draghis
nachfolgerin christine lagarde
übernehmen muss doch auch sie hat
bereits deutlich gemacht dass sie eine
lockere geldpolitik auf lange zeit für
nötig hält keine guten aussichten für
sparer
es geht um milliarden es geht um europa
es geht um unser aller zukunft es macht
also mehr als sinn sich mal genauer
anzugucken was passiert da eigentlich
gerade der große zins hebel wer
profitiert und wer schaut in die röhre
christian kirsch mit einem heute-journal
überblick
der finanzraum des euro hat eine menge
probleme eines der größten die flaue
konjunktur die europäische zentralbank
möchte daher die wirtschaft ankurbeln
indem sie extrem günstige kredite
ermöglicht daher die niedrigen zinsen
schon seit drei jahren verleiht die ezb
ihr geld zinslos an die banken im
euroraum
die sollen nun das billige geld
weiterreichen an die kunden unternehmen
und privatleute und die sollen es
ausgeben damit die wirtschaft in schwung
kommt mit der geldflut will die
zentralbank auch erreichen dass die
geldentwertung also die inflation leicht
ansteigt das ziel 2 prozent allerdings
funktioniert diese politik des billigen
geldes seit jahren nur teilweise die
inflation bleibt gefährlich niedrig und
der aufschwung der mauer
die nullzinspolitik kennt sieger und
verlierer
verlierer sind die sparer ihnen sind
seit 2010 6 148 milliarden an zinsen
entgangen kreditnehmer dagegen sparten
durch den niedrigen zins 290 milliarden
macht ein minus von 3 158 milliarden
euro
die öffentlichen kassen profitieren der
staat so die bundesbank sparte zwischen
2010 und 2018 360 milliarden an zinsen
und wie geht es weiter
um die banken zu zwingen ihr billiges
geld auszugeben verlangt die zentralbank
sei 2014 strafzinsen von den banken wenn
diese ihr geld bei der ezb hinterlegen
dieser zins wurde heute weiter erhöht
damit steigt der druck auf die banker
noch mehr geld zu verleihen und sei es
zu immer niedrigeren zinsen
wir haben gesehen welche enormen
auswirkungen das bereits hatte gucken
wir für moment mal in die zukunft
valerie haller und jetzt wechselt ja
demnächst die ezb spitze
was sagt uns der heutige tag darüber wie
lange diese - zinspolitik noch weiter
gehen wird
ja der heutige tag sagt uns eigentlich
dass die zinspolitik erstmal in stein
gemeißelt ist sogar das umstrittene
anleiheprogramm soll ja so lange laufen
bis die zinsen angehoben werden und das
kann dauern selbst in zwei jahren ist
die inflation noch meilenweit von ihrem
ideal wer zwei prozent entfernt wenn die
prognose der ezb stimmt die notenbank
stößt mit ihrer geldpolitik eindeutig an
ihre grenzen jetzt gibt es zwar noch mal
eine erhöhte dosis derselben medizin
doch je häufiger sie eingesetzt wird
desto mehr lässt die wirkung nach das
haben die vergangenen jahre gezeigt
gefreut haben sich die finanzmärkte über
die bazooka der ezb die niedrigen zinsen
sind seit jahren ihr schmierstoff für
starke kurse selbst wenn es bei den
unternehmen gar nicht so gut läuft
das ist tragisch abschiedsgeschenk an
die märkte kommentiert ein banker wohl
wahr wenn anderswo keine zinsen mehr zu
holen sind werden aktien eben umso
interessanter außerdem schätzen
finanzmärkte die berechenbarkeit der ezb
und da wird sich wohl auf lange sicht
nichts ändern da ist man sich hier auch
ganz sicher die besucher dass mario
draghi valerie herzlichen dank
interessantes thema wichtiges thema und
auf heute.de haben wir noch viel mehr
dazu für sie einen kommentar
heute journal redaktionsleiter wulf
schmiese auf heute.de
man kann darüber streiten ob der
oberbürgermeister von frankfurt am main
unbedingt zur eröffnung der wichtigsten
automesse in seiner stadt reden muss
aber allein das jetzt der verdacht im
raum steht die autoindustrie habe kein
interesse an kritischen worten von einem
der in der praxis dass mit umsetzen muss
was deutschland da versucht unter dem
stichwort mobilitäts wende
allein das zeigt schon wie sehr die
nerven blank liegen bei deutschlands
branche nummer eins und wie nervös alle
sind auf einer internationalen
automobilausstellung die genauso wie
ihre aussteller nach kurs und kompass
sucht und die in der kritik steht wie
nie zuvor
peter feldmann der frankfurter oper war
für die eröffnungsansprachen jedenfalls
nicht mehr vorgesehen
dabei lebt seine stadt nicht nur von der
iaa frankfurt ist ziel von pendlern wie
keine zweite metropole in deutschland
frankfurt hängt am verkehr und weiß
nicht wie lange noch
die autos und die politik peter wagner
berichtet das automobil glänzend
herausgeputzt es fasziniert es ist immer
noch viele deutsche liebstes kind
auch wenn es die protestierenden von
greenpeace heute unsanft mit füßen
treten das auto als klimakiller
beschimpfen der eröffnungsrundgang der
kanzlerin eine hartz von elektroauto zu
elektroauto die klimadiskussion
beherrscht die messe die frage ist nicht
ob wir auch in zukunft automobil sind
sondern wie die elektromobilität ist ja
wenn wir uns die co2 bilanz anschauen
heute noch sozusagen ein entwurf für die
zukunft denn wirklich klimafreundlich
sind die autos erst dann wenn der strom
auch aus erneuerbaren energien entsteht
aber wir sind noch weit davon entfernt
100 prozent erneuerbare energien zu
haben
grünen-chef habe auf der iaa im trocken
mercedes-boss källenius finde die
bundesregierung hätte früher auf die
energiewende setzen müssen
die intensität der diskussion wie sie
jetzt hier in diesem
angeführt wird hätten wir eigentlich vor
45 jahren gebraucht und vor allem die
politische konsequenz daraus also es ist
jetzt echt interessant dass die die
deutsche automobilindustrie der politik
feuer unterm hintern macht stelle bei
der energiewende zu sein
doch kommt der umbruch an bei denen die
die neuen autos kaufen sollen was
erwarten kunden vom elektrofahrzeug die
reichweiten um nur die saison geht
langsam die ladezeit vergessen es ist
wenn das mit der infrastruktur weiter
ausgebaut wird kann ich mir das gut
vorstellen wenn der die reichweite
minimum 800 kilometer hätte und der tank
vergangenen wenige minuten da dann
könnte ich mir überlegen eine hier hat
dazu gaben aber sonst alltägliche die
kundschaft hat klare erwartungen an die
hersteller und im hersteller abend
wünsche an die politik stabile
rahmenbedingungen weil jahr wird re von
investitionsentscheidungen die gehen 15
oder mehr jahre nach vorne aber dann
wünsche ich mich auch eines das wir
nicht dogmatisch sind und das erlebe ich
auch in anderen ländern china kam
hochhaus am beispiel hier die gucken
sich permanent an wie sich das dann
entwickelt das zusammenspiel zwischen
autoherstellern und politik in zeiten
des klimawandels bisher lief es holprig
und hat heute ein opfer gefordert ulrich
matthes chef des automobil-verbandes bda
wer morgens noch die kanzlerin auf der
iaa begrüßt hatte gab heute abend seinen
rücktritt bekannt also die arbeit von
matt es war relativ unglücklich die
autobauer waren wenig zufrieden man hat
sich wirklich mehr versprochen
zb mit dem ausrollen der
elektromobilität das prämien- besser
umgesetzt werden da impulse in die
politik gehen und es ist eigentlich so
gut wie nicht passiert
klimafreundliche mobilität braucht
politik herstellern und verbrauchern
nicht nur neues denken sondern
anscheinend auch neue köpfe so viel ist
klar
die frankfurter automobilausstellung
2009/10 markiert eine zeitenwende klima
pendler arbeitsplätze der kultur kampf
ums auto das ist heute abend titel und
thema bei maybrit illner zu gast unter
anderem der vw chef gleich nach uns hier
im zdf und wir bleiben noch moment beim
thema mobilität der zukunft und da ist
ein hoffnungsträger heute enorm am
schlingern
auch wenn das wort nicht ganz passt es
geht nämlich um die schiene konserve es
geht um die finanzen der deutschen bahn
der bundesrechnungshof sieht eine
signifikante finanzierungslücke bis zum
jahresende fehlten dem konzern fast drei
milliarden euro heißt es in einem papier
das dem zdf vorliegt über neue schulden
kann die bahn das nicht kompensieren da
für sie eine schuldenobergrenze gilt der
rechnungshof fordert die bahn daher auf
den verkauf weiterer konzernteile zu
prüfen zum beispiel ihrer
logistiktochter schenker die stadt köln
muss ihren luftreinhalteplan nachbessern
der aktuelle reicht nicht aus das hat
das zuständige oberverwaltungsgericht
entschieden und damit der deutschen
umwelthilfe recht gegeben
um die grenzwerte für die
luftverschmutzung einzuhalten müssten in
den plan auf fahrverbote für ältere
dieselfahrzeuge aufgenommen werden
allerdings könnten zunächst einzelne
strecken ausreichen die evangelische
kirche in deutschland will sich aktiv an
der rettung schiffbrüchiger migranten
beteiligen
zusammen mit anderen organisationen
werde man einen verein gründen
dieser solle dann ein schiff kaufen das
sagte der ratsvorsitzende bedford strohm
damit setzte der ekd eine resolution des
jüngsten kirchentages um
derzeit verweigern mehrere
mittelmeerstaaten rettungsschiffe die
einfahrt in ihre häfen
die weltgesundheitsorganisation und die
eu wollen gemeinsam gegen impfgegner
vorgehen unter anderem mit kampagnen
gegen fehlinformationen
europäer die sich oder ihre kinder nicht
impfen lassen zum beispiel gegen masern
rechten auch das leben anderer in gefahr
so eu-kommissionspräsident juncker in
europa registrierte die whu in der
ersten jahreshälfte schon mehr
masernfälle als im gesamten jahr 2018
weltweit habe sich die zahl sogar fast
verdreifacht operation yellow hummer
das klingt nach kino action reißer ist
aber unbeabsichtigt denn übersetzt wird
das gleich viel sanfter operation
goldammer benannt nach dem niedlichen
singvogel bloß keine aufregung will die
britische regierung am liebsten hätte
sie ihre bürger über die operation
goldammer komplett im unklaren gelassen
über dem fünfseitigen bericht steht groß
drüber achtung heikel
und das stimmt operation goldammer ist
das szenario dass die regierung in
london entwirft sollte es einen braig
cit geben ohne abkommen mit der eu und
der wird ja jeden tag wahrscheinlicher
es ist das betonen sie heute unisono in
den ministerien ein worst case szenario
aber es liest sich tatsächlich wie ein
düsterer katastrophen plot vielmehr
yellow hummer als goldammer aus london
andreas stamm ein ausgemustertes
kriegsschiff festgemacht von der
londoner city
der premier im dauerwahlkampf an bord
des kreuzers kündigt er den bau von
schiffen an was arbeitsplätze bringen
soll
doch anstatt beim wähler zu punkten
durchkreuzen die der schlechte
neuigkeiten johnsons pläne
das parlament hat die regierung
gezwungen ihre prognosen über den dreck
zieht ohne abkommen zu veröffentlichen
für diesen fall fürchtet sie unter
anderem landesweite proteste und unruhen
massive polizeieinsätze lieferengpässe
bei medikamenten und frischen
lebensmitteln engpässe bei der
benzinversorgung das sind nur die
vorbereitungen die eine vernünftige
regierung trifft es sind die erwartungen
für den schlimmsten fall in der realität
werden wir auf jeden fall für den bhc
rexit ohne abkommen bereit sein
der schlimmste fall doch schon vor drei
wochen waren die dokumente an eine
journalistin gespielt worden die erklärt
nun via twitter
der inhalt sei gleich doch die
überschrift geändert damals war es das
grundlegende szenario was wahrscheinlich
passiere das sind konsequenzen
verursacht durch die politik der
regierung solche dinge sind normal die
folge von naturkatastrophen außerhalb
jeder kontrolle
doch es ist das was diese regierung will
falls sie kein abkommen mit der eu
hinbekommt wonach es aussieht zur
machenden brüssel immer wieder gerüchte
die runde man käme einer lösung einem
geänderten abkommen näher doch der eu
chefunterhändler winkt ab es fehlt an
den geforderten ideen aus london
wir sind weiterhin bereit uns völlig
unvoreingenommen jeden britischen
vorschlag anzuhören berner
rechtsverbindlich und praktikabel ist
keine ideen dafür immer mehr ärger für
den trimble gestern durch die richter
des schottischen berufungsgericht mit
einem urteil dass johnson das parlament
in die fünfwöchige zwangspause geschickt
habe sei ein gesetzesverstoß ein
politisch motivierter versuch das
parlament kaltzustellen
was für interessante zeiten wenn
gerichte im sinne der demokratie
entscheiden gegen einen premier der
unsere demokratie weg schließt vor dem
parlament protestieren abgeordnete der
opposition sie wollen die regierung zur
rechenschaft ziehen für das chaos wollen
wissen wann sie zurück dürfen auf die
parlaments- bänke ob der premierminister
die queen angelogen habe die auf seinen
vorschlag die zwangspause angeordnet
hatte auf keinen fall und ein anderes
das höchste gericht englands war ja auf
unserer seite
jetzt muss der supreme court entscheiden
der wird wohl kommende woche über die
rechtmäßigkeit der zwangspause
entscheiden endgültig stehen auch die
londoner richter auf kriegsfuß mit der
politik des premiers dann dürften seine
abschiedsworte an die schiffbauer der
zukunft auch für ihn gelten viele mir
geht es gut aber bei uns nicht das
könnte der titel eines neuen
befindlichkeits romans seien aus der
psycho poesie ecke es ist aber viel mehr
mir geht es gut aber uns nicht ist in
einem satz die lagebeschreibung einer
generation die forscher von allensbach
haben den 30 bis 59 jährigen in
deutschland auf den zahn gefühlt sie
haben ein bild gewonnen dass wir uns
genauer angucken sollten eine generation
die rein von den nackten
wirtschaftsdaten so gut dasteht wie
keine vor ihr und die dennoch große
sorgen hat es ist auch der blick auf ein
reiches land das verunsichert ist
christian von rechenberg
es gibt so einen gewissen finger den man
zeigt oder den vogel
oder die vsg direkt ein shirt und einen
zum bremsen zwingt ja und kein abstand
hält
man muss einen nerven kosten im rahmen
ohne ende hat auch include ja auch und
die erfahrung von 100.000 kilometern im
jahr auf der straße wenn es einer merkt
dann er ist auf jeden fall mehr geworden
mehr kochen des blutig oder keiner es
fühlt sich nicht gut an
unser miteinander sagt die generation
mitte die 30 bis 59 jährigen
die leistungsträger wenn hier fast 70
prozent die bilanz ziehen deutschland
verdient das prädikat eine
ellbogengesellschaft zu sein dann ist
das schon bemerkenswert eine große
mehrheit beklagt zunehmende
aggressivität vor allem auf der straße
und im netz wachsenden zeitdruck viele
beobachten mehr egoismus das regeln
seltener eingehalten werden
aber auch mehr fremdenfeindlichkeit auch
wenn die studie heute nur gefühle wieder
gibt der hass im netz beispielsweise ist
allgegenwärtig auch weil wir mehr denn
je auf dauer empfangen sind
der stammtisch von heute hockt und hass
online wenn sich gruppen bilden und
abschließen dann fallen die hemmungen
aggressiv herabwürdigen diffamierend zu
sprechen
das ist ein sehr schlechtes zeichen der
geist ist das sozusagen aus der flasche
und wir kriegen ihn nicht mehr dahin
zurück und so hat bald jeder von uns
seine geister begegnung meist eine
negative
ich glaube das miteinander spielt nicht
mehr so eine große rolle und wird er zur
seite gedrängt
wenn jemand ihnen schlecht geht oder so
dass man einfach vorbei gedacht dass man
mich fragt okay dass man nicht mehr
hilfsbereit ist und denen die helfen
gegen gaffer saures das fand ich auch
ein ganz bemerkenswertes ergebnis dass
ein gutes fünftel der mittleren
generation sagt ich kenne leute denen
ich das zutrauen dass sie aggressiv
werden gegenüber rettungskräften was ist
los mit uns liegt es am geld kann nicht
sein
44 prozent sehen ihre wirtschaftliche
lage besser als vor fünf jahren
eine erklärung für die expertin wir sind
sensibler geworden wer rechte und
freiheiten erringt verteidigt sie auch
deswegen werden heute auch formen von
verhalten als aggressiv wahrgenommen und
auch skandalisiert die hätte man früher
als normales vielleicht unangenehm ist
aber irgendwie auch hin zu nehmendes
hinzunehmenden teil der alltags
interaktion interpretiert auch im club
macht sich so seine gedanken er sieht
das problem woanders
ich würde sagen die schnelllebigkeit
unserer zeit alters jeder muss noch mehr
schaffen muss möglichst zwei berufe
haben um über die runden zu kommen und
um sich den gewissen luxus zu gönnen und
wenn sie dann den luxus haben wollen sie
denn noch auskosten und ausnutzen und
dann geben sie gas um eben vorne dabei
zu sein
wer kann da helfen familie und eltern
sagen 85 prozent in der studie mit
bessere erziehung zur rücksicht und
respekt da liegt noch viel arbeit vor
uns
packen wir es an schön dass er gerade
einen philosophen am steuer erleben
durften jetzt nochmal nachrichten im
steuerstreit mit frankreich hat google
zugestimmt knapp eine milliarde euro zu
überweisen
500 millionen als strafe fast noch
einmal soviel als nachzahlung das land
wirft dem internet konzern seit jahren
vor in frankreich aktiv steuern zu
vermeiden
wegen ähnlicher vorwürfe musste google
bereits in italien und großbritannien
nach zahlen allerdings deutlich kleinere
summen google verbucht den größten teil
seiner europäischen erlöse in irland wo
ein besonders niedriger steuersatz gilt
seit jahren klagen hebammenverbände über
schwierige arbeitsbedingungen nun
bestätigt ein neues gutachten einen
massiven personalmangel
laut dem wissenschaftlichen dienst des
bundestages muss fast die hälfte der
hebammen in deutschland drei gebärende
gleichzeitig versorgen
das berichtet die neue osnabrücker
zeitung medizinische fachgesellschaften
empfehlen eine eins-zu-eins-betreuung
erst die balearen nun das spanische
festland schwere unwetter haben dort
mindestens zwei menschenleben gefordert
in drei provinzen gilt die höchste
warnstufe viele schulen bleiben
geschlossen
südlich von valencia fehlen in wenigen
stunden rund 300 liter regen pro
quadratmeter und verwandelten einen
fluss in eine reißende fluten 200
anwohner wurden in sicherheit gebracht
es sind die schlimmsten unwetter in der
provinz seit beginn der
wetteraufzeichnung das hier ist der
einfachste und zugleich tiefgründigste
exportschlager von simbabwe zu sehen wie
hier mittlerweile auch in new york dass
es nicht einfach nur eine
sitzgelegenheit es ist eine bank die
halt gibt
in einem land wie simbabwe gnadenlose
diktatur katastrophale wirtschaftslage
leidet fast jeder vierte an depression
und es gibt für über 16 millionen
menschen dort gerade mal zwei
psychiatrische fachärzte simbabwe ist
bettelarm und gleichzeitig sehr reich
weil es menschen hat wie die die sandra
theis uns jetzt zeigt die für alle in
not eine stütze
die größte und die einzige viermal hat
versucht sich das leben zu nehmen sie
war verzweifelt
das war vor ein paar jahren als sich
alles schlagartig veränderte mein mann
hatte mich aus dem haus geworfen
ich musste zurück ins haus meiner mutter
ziehen
als ich hier ankam war ich unglücklich
dann starb auch noch meine jüngere
schwester und hinterließ mir die
verantwortung für ihre beiden kinder
das war alles zu viel für mich dann
findet sie auch noch heraus dass ihr ex
mann sie mit hiv infiziert hat ist
verletzt und weiß nicht weiter
ihre mutter schickt sie zu einer go go
go go's so nennen die simbabwer
liebevoll großmütter diese gogos in
harare sitzen auf freundschafts bänken
und hören einfach zu sowie gogo beauty
maria sie hilft menschen in seelischer
not kostenlos keiner kommune circuit ich
sage ihnen nicht was sie konkret tun
sollen ich fordere sie auf über ihre
situation nachzudenken und helfe ihnen
selbst einen weg zu finden wie sie ihr
problem lösen könnten die ballone solche
richtige therapeuten gibt es im
krisengeschüttelten simbabwe kaum
großmutter schon
sie besitzen die weisheit des alters
gogos haben zeit und geduld der
psychotherapeutischen die bahn da
erkannte ihr potenzial er bildete die
ersten von ihnen aus every kommune jede
gemeinde in afrika und auf der ganzen
welt großmütter stellen sie sich vor
dass wir diesen teil der bevölkerung
nutzen sie mit den nötigen kenntnissen
versehen und unterstützen sie könnten
millionen von menschen erreichen in
sofia die omas auf den bänken warten
nicht nur auf patienten sie gehen in
ihren gemeinden gezielt zu menschen die
hilfe brauchen wie wichtig das ist wurde
klar als sich eine ehemalige patientin
chip an dass das leben nahm
als sich mit erik us mutter am telefon
sprach
als sie mir erzählte dass erika sich das
leben genommen hat da habe ich sie
gefragt warum sie nicht zu mir in die
klinik gekommen sind und ihre mutter
sagte dass sie nicht die 15 dollar für
den bus hatten um zu mir zu fahren
die go go auf der bank hat mein leben
gerettet sagt frey sie habe ihr geholfen
die neue situation zu akzeptieren und
besser damit umzugehen eigentlich hätte
wohl heute schäme ich mich nicht mehr
wenn ich im krankenhaus mein medikament
gegen hiv abhole
und was die geistig behinderten kinder
meiner schwester angeht so betrachte ich
sie jetzt als meine eigenen es ist jetzt
ok die gogos sind so erfolgreich dass
das konzept zum exportschlager wurde
nicht nur in afrika selbst in new york
stehen inzwischen die ersten bänke es
ist so einfach die weisheit des alters
wir sollten sie nutzen das können wir
alle von simbabwe lernen und damit sagt
das heute-journal team tschüs und danke
herzlich für ihr interesse
dass ich dann auch hanna zimmermann treu
zum 0 30 in heute plus bis morgen
[Musik]
die namen meine damen und herren da
kommt auch schon gleich wieder der
nächste ehemalige hurrikan heran
das ist ex gabriel und dieses ex gabriel
bringt uns morgen einige dichtere wolken
und regen die meisten von uns aber
dürfen sich dank der hochs friederike
und gaia auf sonnenschein einstellen und
das nächste tief ignatz das kommt erst
in der nächsten woche bei uns an
bei der nacht also regnet ist bereits
hier im nordwesten da kommen diese
regenwolken von ex gabriel an
sonst ist es zum teil klar und die
temperaturen sinken unter klarem himmel
am alpenrand auf 7 grad in
norddeutschland bleibt es bei 16 bis 14
grad milder
tagsüber wird es da aber gar nicht so
sehr viel wärmer da sind das 18 19 grad
richtung mittelgebirge steigen die werte
auf 20 bis 22 grad
der regen der nacht zieht schon im laufe
des vormittags weiter erreicht die
mittelgebirge dann reißen die wolken an
der nordsee und auch nordöstlich der
elbe bereits wieder auf bei billigen
nordwest wird auch in süddeutschland ist
es zum teil morgen stärker bewölkt
südlich von mannheim stuttgart und
nürnberg aber strahlt zum teil richtig
schön die sonne und deswegen wird es
dort auch am wärmsten
da erwarten uns höchsttemperaturen
zwischen 24 und 26 grad
am samstag gibt's noch ein paar letzte
regenfälle im südosten und im osten
deutschlands der sonntag aber bringt uns
überall sonnenschein und mit etwas glück
oder pech je nachdem wie sie es sehen
können sogar 30 grad erreicht werden
schönen abend noch